[Applause]
[Music]
2020 is a difficult year for everyone
however you look at it coronavirus has
paralyzed pretty much everything
despite this take note because
everything points to the middle east
giving us a lot to talk about in the
near future and look we're not exactly
talking about good news we're talking
about crises conflict and deep-rooted
clashes just normal for the Middle East
I guess then
how could it get even worse in 2020 well
friends official partic prepare for a
new episodes and the eternal conflict
between Israel and Palestine a nice easy
video for one of my first videos totally
non-controversial
thanks very much guys for decades the
Israelis and Palestinians have
accumulated more than enough reasons to
fight and lucky them now there's a new
one I'm talking about the so called deal
of the century the Trump
administration's plan to supposedly
achieve peace between Israel and
Palestine and I say supposedly because
it seems for now that what Trump is
doing is pushing Israel and Palestine to
their most critical moment in the last
40 years and let's remember they've had
a lot of critical moments in the last 40
years if no one prevents it Israel is
finally going to annex Jewish
settlements on the West Bank in other
words it will incorporate into the
Israeli States a part of the territory
that has historically been considered as
a part of a hypothetical Palestinian
state and this brings up several
questions what is happening in the
Middle East are we really facing the
deal of the century does Trump's plan
have winners and losers and why does
Israel want to annex Jewish settlements
more importantly than all of that though
why does the solution to the
israel-palestine conflict seem farther
away than ever here on visual politic
and in this video we will answer all
these questions but first let's look at
some history
[Music]
seven decades of conflict to really
understand this conflict it is essential
to travel back to the first half of the
20th century
at that time anti-semitism was growing
in Europe so more and more Jews migrated
to the land of their ancestors as you
can imagine this type of migration
really accelerated after World War Two
the horrors of the Holocaust increased
the Jewish exodus to Palestine the
Jewish people were very clear that they
needed their own state at that time
Palestine was under British rule and the
problems between the Arabs and the Jews
were increasing
[Music]
so the United Nations took up the matter
with one of the most famous resolutions
and its entire history resolution 1:8 1
this resolution was one in which the UN
proposed to divide Palestine into two
states one of 14,000 square kilometers
under Hebrew room in which there would
be a 60% Jewish population but also a
40% Arab population the other slightly
smaller states of 11,000 square
kilometers would be that of the
Palestinian people where the Jews would
represent only 2% of the population
Jerusalem Bethlehem and the other holy
places were also placed under
international rule the Jews accepted the
resolution but not the Arabs and that is
how a conflict that has spread over the
last seven decades began to give you an
idea the day after proclaiming its
independence Israel was invaded by the
joint armies of five Arab countries
of course the income of this contest was
a clear victory for the Jewish army a
victory with which Israel expanded its
territory another 40 percent and this is
very important because the expanded
borders of the 1949 armistice are what
the United Nations no accept at that
time the Arabs gave up proclaiming the
state of Palestine in such a way that
Egypt occupied the Gaza Strip and Jordan
ended up with a West Bank the situation
remains so until 1967 the so-called
sects day war a war that resulted in a
new victory for the Israeli army this
time as real took over the Golan Heights
on the borders with Syria East Jerusalem
and the rest of the West Bank to place
the border with Jordan on the River
Jordan Klepper naming their egypt was
also robbed of the Gaza Strip and the
Sinai Peninsula
since then there have been more wars
such as the yom kippur or the lebanese
wars but there was also a time in
between to negotiate the most successful
negotiations were those that took place
in the Camp David agreements with Egypt
Israel returned the Sinai Peninsula to
Egypt and it was to be the only
territory that regained the same status
as it had prior to 1967 in the early
1980s Israel definitively annexed the
Golan Heights then the Jerusalem act
recognized the entirety of the holy city
as its capital meanwhile in the West
Bank the various conservative and
progressive governments of Israel opted
for the route of fait accompli and
pushed forward with the construction of
tens and tens even hundreds of Jewish
settlements to discuss this issue in
detail in a video that I'll link in the
description the fact is that with these
settlements Israel directly defines
international law but why because the
Geneva Convention expressly prohibits
the transfer of civilian populations to
military occupied territories the point
is is that it is precisely Israel's
policy towards East Jerusalem and the
settlements that are drawn on the
horizon that will be crucial in order to
reach an agreement that will resolve
this conflict once and for all
then Forex part the Palestinian response
only contributed to making matters worse
under Yasser Arafat for years the
Palestinian Liberation Organization
attacks and violent actions multiplied
and it was not until the 1990s the
Palestine sat down to negotiate with the
Hebrew state and Madrid and in Oslo
there he made advances towards
self-government in Palestine but in
practice it was still very limited if
one thing seemed clearer than it was
that solution to the arab-israeli
conflict would be the so-called
two-state solution however in the last
25 years very little progress has been
made
Azrael has not stopped building
settlements and the Palestinians have
not ended the violence and their violent
actions have never delivered the results
that they actually wanted in fact if
there is one thing we can highlight
during the last 25 years is precisely
that Israel has been the clear vector in
this dispute and we're not just speaking
from a military point of view for
example as we saw in this video
relations of the Hebrew state with Arab
countries are now better than ever
in addition Arafat's death divided the
Palestinians into two separate factions
on one hand his Fatah heirs who dominate
the West Bank and on the other the
radical Hamas the Palestinian arm of the
Muslim Brotherhood that has control of
the Gaza Strip
two factions that are continually
fighting each other over the Palestinian
leadership so you see that while
Palestine has had a very weak leadership
and Israel the exact opposite has been
true especially during the last 11 years
when the country has been ruled by
Benjamin Netanyahu the longest-serving
Prime Minister in the entire history of
the country and then as if that wasn't
complicated enough we drop Donald Trump
right into the middle of the picture
check the sex today's agreement is a
historic opportunity for the
Palestinians to finally achieve an
independent state of their very own
[Music]
the deal of the century
no look no one asked him to but Trump
began his presidency by committing to do
everything that he could to achieve
ultimate peace between Israel and
Palestine it's what become known as
entropion language the deal of the
century that was three years ago since
then a lot has happened and it's not
clear that any of his actions have
contributed to the slightest to bringing
peace closer together or at least
facilitating negotiations the decision
to move the US Embassy to Jerusalem was
a turning point in this attempt to
improve a completely stalled peace
process on December 6 2017 at my
directions the United States finally and
officially recognized Jerusalem as the
true capital of Israel today we follow
through of this recognition and open our
embassy in the historic and sacred land
of Jerusalem the Trump administration
directly challenged a 1980 UN Security
Council resolution a resolution calling
on countries to withdraw their
diplomatic missions from Jerusalem as a
protest measure for Israel's annexation
of East Jerusalem
of course the lack of Arab response
exposed the weakness of Palestinian
political movements Fatah broke off any
negotiations with the United States but
no one listened to the Hamas radicals
call for a third intifada but luckily no
one listened to them either
meanwhile other countries showed that
this conflict matters less and less to
them and that they have other much more
important priorities such as the clash
with Iran and other matters at the US
and ezreal have in common
not to mention moreover that other
countries are not really in a position
to demand very much either for example
put yourself in the place of I don't
know
Saudi Arabia imagine Prince Salman
calling the White House to protest hey
Donald I think it's terrible it's really
really bad that you've put your embassy
in Jerusalem
can you imagine Trump's answer well what
can I say Mohammed you whacked this yogi
actually know you mention it I've really
got to go and that would be the end of
it toward peace we're looking seriously
at peace and maybe ultimately peace in
the whole of the Middle East the fact is
is that the deal of the century in spite
of everything moved forward of course
it's nothing like what it was cracked up
to be
in much the same way as Trump's entire
presidency as turned out
let me explain for starters a plan that
has never included the Palestinians
cannot be called an agreement but not
only will the new agreement not bring
peace but everything indicates that it
would cause the conflicts to erupt again
why well in the u.s. they're pretty
clear about checking Trump releases
Mideast peace plan that strongly favors
Israel New York Times the club
administration's plan breaks
international law UN resolutions and 60
years of US diplomacy the deal of the
century ladies and gentlemen no half
measures
Trump approaches the problem by backing
all the demands of Israel and none of
the Palestinians
well not exactly none the Palestinians
want their capital in East Jerusalem no
problem however East and West are sort
of relative concepts for Trump so II
took a map when he said let's see these
two wards in the East East Jerusalem job
done there you are this is going to be
the capital that the Palestinians claim
problem solved
who wants to go and get McDonald's and
it's basically the ordinary concession
if you can even call it now so the
question is disrupt think the
Palestinians were gonna take this lying
down
well no that's why you simply pulled out
the checkbook and promised them fifty
billion dollars and AIDS to develop the
future Palestinian state the Palestinian
answer you could probably guess for
Heroes
No according to the borders accepted by
the UN those drawn from the 1949
armistice the Palestinians would stay in
the Gaza Strip and occupy 70% of the
West Bank in addition they have been
promised that both territories would be
connected by an underground tunnel but
any resemblance to a country is pure
coincidence the West Bank that the Trump
agreement proposes would be a kind of
Swiss cheese with towns connected to
each other by isolated ruins through
tunnels flyovers police checks and so on
and that is the best-case scenario but
pay attention because the main
contribution of the White House's plan
is truly shocking No
how could the Palestinians be
compensated if Ezra gets 30% of the West
Bank how can we compensate the
Palestinian state for turning it into a
kind of Swiss cheese with territories
connected to each other buying literal
labyrinths and without even having full
competition in terms of ports or
airports how can we compensate them for
Israel holding on to the fair title
Jordan Valley and almost all of the
water sources
[Music]
well Trump saw it very clearly he took
him up again and said let's see I see an
area here in Israel that is empty why
don't we give that to the Palestinians
problem solved let's all go get
mcdonalds and then I'm sure some advisor
who understood Israeli issues a little
more clearly than the president which to
be fair could be literally any adviser
said to him but mr. president there's
nothing in that area because it's the
Negev desert can you imagine that
can you imagine Trump's reaction what it
possibly might be anyway who knows but
at this point the question we should
really ask ourselves is in a
hypothetical parallel universe where the
Palestinians accepted this deal
something they've already said no to in
this actual real world would there
finally be an independent Palestinian
state and the answer is no because you
see Trump's plan says that in four years
and if they've been very good then
well maybe maybe they could form a state
by the way a state with only partial
sovereignty it would be a demilitarized
state with no control over its borders
or airspace they wouldn't even be free
to allow me the president's plane to
take off as you can imagine the Israelis
today are delighted but in the long run
all this will bring them problems what
kind of problems check this out the age
of regrets
there is no doubts Ezreal is enjoying a
golden era
for many years now their existence has
not been threatened Palestinians are
giving them fewer and fewer problems
their economy has experienced an
incredible boom and has become a
paradise for startups and on top of that
they now have Washington completely on
st.
and yes some may be thinking but wait a
minute grant hasn't the United States
always been an important ally for Israel
well yes it has but Trump has gone much
much further
for example Trump has acknowledged the
annexation of the Golan Heights the
annexation of East Jerusalem and its
distinction as Israel's capital he's cut
aid to the Palestinians and closed their
diplomatic mission in Washington
[Music]
so the question is is there anything he
skipped in sinking the morale of the
Palestinians well yes and that's what
the US Secretary of State was in charge
of listen to what make Pompey look has
to see the establishment of Israeli
civilian settlements in the West Bank is
not per se inconsistent with
international law
now as you can imagine the Palestinians
have not been best pleased with this
they've said a thousand times that they
don't want to even hear from Trump
[Music]
but of course when you consider that
Netanyahu has not spoken out either way
about giving up an area of them again
then you wonder why on earth as the
Trump administration drawn up a plan
that no one wants and why considering
that would you call it the deal of the
century
well in the end what this all boils down
to is very simple and is summarized best
here Donald Trump gives Israel the green
light to an annex occupied lands
economists know all of this has occurred
a very turbulent time for Israeli
politics Netanyahu has been a solid
leader over the last decades but
Israel's electoral system is so
complicated that it practically always
forces large coalition's large
coalition's compromising many desperate
parties
and as you can imagine constant
negotiation is extremely exhausting just
ask my girlfriend and Netanyahu had a
tough time last year
things got so complicated that he has to
face three elections in a row for
failing to reach a sufficient majority
to govern and in the end you had to make
a deal with his main political adversary
which is never a good thing
just ask my girlfriend Netanyahu and
Gant agree to form unity Israeli
government Prime Minister will remain in
office for 18 months before handing
position to his rifle the Guardian under
this Agreement Netanyahu will cease to
be Israel's prime minister in November
2021 and that leads us to think that
he's very clear about what he wants his
legacy to be the annexation of the West
Bank partially occupied by Jewish
settlements unity deal allows Prime
Minister to begin advancing West Bank
annexation from July 1st times of Israel
a pretense that as we have already seen
has been driven by the explicit
endorsement of Trump himself however
Israel should be prepared for the
consequences this annexation could
trigger a Palestinian state like the one
Trump's proposed would hardly be viable
it would be more like a Swiss cheese
than what we would recognize as a
country and how attractive would that be
who would invest in a country that
doesn't even control his borders or its
airspace in a country that is subject to
all kinds of external controls what
viable future could it possibly have
ending the two-state solution by
annexing the West Bank could bring with
it a resumption of violence in the area
[Music]
and let's be very clear a future without
a Palestinian state is not a good thing
for Israel it involves perpetuating the
conflict with the consequent economic
and military cost while inflicting
massive significant human damage on
Palestine because when it comes down to
it the current situation basically means
that the Palestinians are condemned
forever to poverty
now look Israel is the only solid
democracy in this area of the world and
it is also a technological power whose
contribution to the development of
humanity is more than remarkable it's
something we've talked about previously
on visual politic but that shouldn't and
doesn't mean that they have carte
blanche for everything any case dear
listeners if there's one thing that's
clear as the Trump's plan for peace
today is anything but peace do know it's
up to you guys do you think this eternal
conflict will one day find a solution
what do you think of the Trump
administration's proposal and finally do
you think Netanyahu will eventually dare
to annex a West Bank leave your answer
in the comments below we really hope you
enjoyed this video please hit like if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos that are coming out
every week have you clicked the little
button down there you'll get updates
whenever we release a new one also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsidered media podcast they provided
the vocals on this episode that we're
not my dulcet tones also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you next
time if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider @ww re consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast